from navigating obstacle courses
to playing team sports
and creating handicrafts
120 000 palestinian children are
experiencing a typical summer holiday
i love the slide the jumping castle and
trampoline if there wasn't this summer
camp i would have been at home for the
entire vacation
the camp has a variety of activities
and lots of fun games i wish it was the
entire summer holiday but even though
it's for one week i have a lot of fun
and i am happy
the initiative is organized by the un
relief and works agency for palestine
refugees
these summer camps last only for one
week but they provide a lot of support
physical and mental activities for the
children of gaza it's a small gesture
that makes a big difference in the lives
of these impoverished children
more than a million people defend a new
agency for food health care and
education assistance and families spend
the little money they do have on food
rather than entertainment
but these camps are about more than just
fun and games
the un says they provide indirect
psychological support to children
traumatized by the war
educational activities aimed at helping
the youngsters to manage loss anger and
stress
if you track the symptoms and signs of
children and as i will find higher rates
of trauma symptoms
higher rates of anxiety high rates of
you know sadness and so on
and one study that was published by save
the children foundation they recorded
almost 80 percent of such symptoms among
children
the camps may last only 7 days
but for these children it's a chance to
enjoy the simple pleasures other
youngsters take for granted
you must see it al jazeera gaza